hello welcome back everybody
[Music]
those chords don't go together here we
go
all right that song was like my os
trying to figure out how to make a
folder um welcome back to the quarter
digital podcast everybody episode 149.
we've got
fenner
what's up
we've got jonah
we've got jordan
hi
what's going on everybody
hope you guys are having a good day yeah
i hope you enjoyed our our
our um preamble to this podcast and and
now
um
now we will begin
yeah so
it's been a great like it was just a
fast day from the beginning like i feel
and i just got back from atlanta but i
don't know what it's been like all week
but it felt like
we're in the middle of like an everyone
all hands on deck like
there's a lot of things that are ending
and there's a lot of things that are
starting right now and it's very like
everything could just blow up in our
faces at any given point so we're all
just kind of yeah a lot of plates yeah
spinning lots of plates
but yeah that is in a great way yeah it
is kind of a transitional time of year
honestly i mean i know people are
starting school again but also there
happens to be this natural rhythm a lot
of times when we hit the fall or the
early fall
where we transitioned from a lot of the
things that we were doing at the
beginning of the year
and the summer and we start thinking
about okay now
we start thinking about not just this
fall but also next year
yeah and uh
i always like this time of year the
weather changes you know you get even
even in la you can even smell a little
bit of the leaf change in la as time
goes by which you know that's not what i
smell about it depends on where you have
that well yeah it depends on where you
are yeah definitely hunter street
definitely does no not so much yeah i
could saw something else but not that
good
so wha what were you doing in atlanta
jonah
um well it was my first time in atlanta
so um
actually this is cool so my my
girlfriend rachel um took the lsat a
couple months ago in the podcast room
she took it that's right i remember
right yeah there yeah
yeah and she ended up getting into a law
school at emory blah blah blah
no not blah blah blah pretty big deal
yeah just got a name
whatever yeah emery's just like an
awesome law school and so i i went down
there for the first time to uh help her
move in and um you know do that whole
thing so there's a lot of media building
stuff um
but
it was really cool because
i i only realized the day that i landed
but um one of my the theater drama like
arts teacher that um
was at my high school lives 20 minutes
uh out of atlanta like the city where
because we're like smacked up in the
middle of the city and so i texted her
i haven't seen her since 2016
yeah 17 and i was like hey i'm in the
city and her second text was like oh
come over for dinner and i was like oh
this is crazy um she i didn't even have
a beard when when you act like you're
you were in high school like four years
ago hey were you were you born with a
beard were both you and fenner born with
beards it's true well no what they did
is when i came out they said this kid
looks weird because it doesn't have a
beard and they just gave me like they
knew that i would have a beard so they
just put a beard on me they're just like
they just
yeah just yeah like that fix that fix
that now yeah yeah um but it was really
cool i got to see her she has like a
whole family now um and we just talked
about i did like a lot of theater in
high school it was that was kind of like
my thing and it was towards the end of
high school that i realized like i
really wanted to get into filmmaking
that was like the transition was like i
did theater and i and i mixed all the
music live as well like i was i was a
sound engineer for the school like the
head of the av club
it was like really cool wait was this in
atlanta get it no no so yeah so i did
when i was like 12
i moved to india and i did high school
in like the foothills of the himalaya in
india from like 12 to when i was like 18
when i moved away um
and so you went to high school you went
to high school in india yeah it was like
super random to the point where like uh
it had i was in like middle school it
was like seventh grade yeah seventh
grade and just one day i came home from
school my dad was like
he's a teacher and he's like i went to
this conference uh
learning in the brain and
i met this woman teaches in india and
they're looking for a math teacher you
guys like you guys want to go or
and i was like when he was like i don't
know maybe like
for the next school year like a couple
months from now and i was like pretty
solidified in my community and
it was like we had a whole conversation
i have two sisters my mom and i were
like whatever we'll go and then
yeah i didn't know it'd be like my whole
high school career up to like college
when i did that because i was like in
middle school i didn't really how many
years were you there for what grade six
five years yeah so it was like eighth
grade ninth grade tenth grade
eleventh grade twelfth grade wow wow
uh the school you went to did everyone
stay there or were there people like
moving in and out all the time well so
it was a i always have to like qualify
this so it was like
it's a prestigious like boarding school
private boarding school but
my dad was a teacher so
he's like low-key a genius like he i
didn't pay for a private education
i i they didn't pay for housing right
like all my meals were paid for because
i just worked at the school so like my
parents
figured out this little trick that if
you're like a teacher
and you do boarding schools like your
kids are pretty much set um and it was
like a huge privilege that i had for
them to like
let me do that and so all my sisters and
i got like a private school education
for for no money like i had a friend do
that at notre dame his dad was a
law professor and
they settled there
and all he had
this is a
classic like
uh
irish italian catholic family
they had eight children they had eight
children
oh yeah
all of them all of them went to notre
dame
well it's like it's under that same
under that same thing like i don't know
how much money the school
you know
gave out there but it was yeah i think
it's really like i i don't know if i
could get into a prestigious school
prestigious school i can't even say the
word right i don't deserve to go to a
school like that right like
you know and i like test it in but it's
like yeah if you're a teacher at the
school your kids get to go to the school
and it was a really awesome experience
and and that's where i did fall in love
with filmmaking and i i found that
through theater um
towards the end of my time there i
actually like um i was introduced by
bethany oakey who was the theater
director
and when i was in that scene to like a
filmmaker that was an alumnus of the
school alex who came to the school and
he's like you got any kids who would
like
be interested in coming and like filming
stuff with me and so is me and this
other guy uh aman
and he just like took us out and we went
i spent like a couple weeks i didn't
have to go to school and uh i went to
these nature reserves um
in northern india and we were just doing
nature photography and videography like
tigers and um you know leopards and
all this stuff all that there's wild or
wild yeah it was like oh wow like
expansive nature reserves um in northern
india
and like
it was the first time i had touched a
camera you know like i was just like
you know i was a theater kid i was like
super technically literate i had built
my own pc like i was like in that vibe
but i was like the minute i went out
with him and i was got the chance to
shoot i was we were shooting on like
canon dslrs i just like my life was
never the same like i was like oh this
is the thing like this is every
component of what i like to do like in
one thing because i love theater i love
the technical element and it was just it
just clicked and like he was a huge
mentor to me and bethany who who had
been kind of my mentor through high
school in a lot of ways was like
yeah this makes sense for you you know
like this is like the evolution and it
was really cool seeing her again because
i got to tell her about what i do now
and it's like i don't know how many kids
she's mentored that like go through
life and end up like landing in a
creative field because a theater for
high school students is really about
finding a sense of community and it's
really about finding right you know
passion and a way to like
do that type of thing so oftentimes they
don't end up actually becoming
creative
and that's not a problem that's not a
problem at all you know um they end up
being very yeah it's way more important
to just find your yeah like you said
your community but also your
self-confidence yeah
that's the hardest thing about it you
know i didn't do theater but i did
you know battle of the bands and that
kind of stuff and yeah it's basically
theater i mean you got to get up there
and play a song that you're really not
very good at
and
you know and what was doing you played
it yeah i want to know everything
um well okay so
uh one year we did
hulk hogan put out an album believe it
or not
and he had one song called the beach
patrol
and uh hell yeah it was
it was something like this
it was my brother it was my brother and
all of his friends
and they were the beach patrol and then
me and uh two other guys were the band
and they did they we played the beach
patrol and they came out and did this
whole
act and this song and dance while we
played the beach patrol that was my
first experience so you guys won the
battle of bands
no we did we didn't win unfortunately
they didn't like our sound enough you
know yeah it was two you were too ahead
of your time was the problem right
exactly and then we were even more ahead
of our time the next time when i was in
a band called band electronica
uh which was electronic prog rock
uh that i just don't really think quite
hit you know the
early 2000s pop genre in the right way
you know so we didn't win that year
either but we had some we had some
really progressive sounds that year
that's good that's what you know it was
all about the art it wasn't about
winning
well what it did was it it gave us
everybody
like you're saying about theater it
gives you that
self-confidence to stand up there in
front of a crowd and
and just do something and do something
that's rehearsed and add a little
creativity to it and
put yourself out there and that's
honestly you have to do that in life our
school like didn't have a we
we had like theater and it lasted about
half a semester and then they asked it
because there wasn't like enough budget
or
interest they had a very small high
school like there was like 40 kids in my
graduating class so
we had we had a film program but it was
online
and not like moderated at all so it was
basically like
all right go film some stuff so it was
basically like me and my buddies would
go and like
um
just film random little short film
things around the school
my final project for that was
actually pretty cool we had a
in grade 11 and 12 you can get into this
class called outdoor recreational
leadership
which was run by this amazing guy mitch
salkers he established the program
one of the best you know people i've
ever met he's amazing and it's basically
like
it takes up your entire second semester
it's all your blocks of like classes for
the day but you're essentially getting
your physical education credit your
english credit a leadership credit
uh and a planning credit
um and essentially what you do is you're
doing these big like expeditions and
stuff so it starts during the winter
and we're doing like ski touring stuff
where you'd go on like a ski expedition
and dig snow caves and sleep in snow
caves or
go on these crazy hikes and stuff yeah
that sounds awesome yeah and so for my
my final project for my film class is i
started day one of that class
and basically filmed like a mini
documentary style thing for our outdoor
recreational leadership for that year so
it was like see you were just credit
hacking in some
quasi-educational environment yeah
you've got to hang out on a mountain all
day my final semester of high school was
i had three blocks
because one of the blocks was basically
a free block and so i would like
edit footage during that and then the
rest of it
because i was a second year student
you've kind of done a lot of like the
training like your avalanche safety
training and stuff you're already like
qualified for that and like yeah yeah so
kind of we would just like chill out
and like go skiing sometimes or like
yeah um we do like search and rescue
training and that's it was amazing uh
survival skills stuff building shelter
that's a really i think important part
of life that uh i can't i'm surprised
the american education system is at
least in the public schools when i was
in them was a lot more cut and dry
they didn't have those kind of outside
the box
type
situations for kids but i think that
that that kind of stuff is really good
you know if you took a class on that and
then you took a class on
personal finance
you're set for life
yeah and then you all you need to do
after that is take one on like
the federal reserve and the credit
system and then you know
kind of
you'd be you'd be good you'd be pretty
well-rounded yeah it was a that was
definitely like
extremely
extremely cool that final semester
because it was basically like
this weird transition from just like
crunching trying to finish all these
like in canada we have um provincial
exams which is basically like your
finals i guess
and uh so it was like cramming to get
through those my first semester of grade
12 and then
second semester i was like oh i
i just i'm chilling like it was really
it was uh it was pretty awesome was this
a public school yeah i don't know
yeah but our teacher mr salkers like he
fully established this program and yeah
i think it's in a few different schools
now and
it's like a ton of hard work on his part
but it was a it was really amazing so i
he's uh just retired in the last couple
years
very cool that's really neat yeah i i
had a buddy who was from uh quebec and
um i don't know if this is true for all
canadian school systems but
there's
there's this concept of grade 13 isn't
there
uh that might be a quebec's
always like it's very different from the
right they've got their little okay yeah
yeah there's there's a lot of stuff that
is extremely different um okay
so yeah grade 13 i think is probably one
of those things okay yeah and i don't
mean to speak for the entirety of quebec
or anything but it just he had there was
something about he came in late
he wasn't he wasn't born at you know the
cutoff times or whatever
he was just
a year older than everybody for some
reason and uh he said it had to do maybe
he was just maybe they held him back or
something but yeah he made that i was
like oh yeah there's yeah
but uh
he invited him
but he yeah he was just a year older
than everybody for some reason so we
always used to call him the old man
um it was funny
but yeah i didn't know if that was true
for the entire system over there
where did he where did you go to school
in florida oh okay well here we go um
yeah so snow caves leopards go literally
i'm listening to you guys and i'm like
um it's like a movie a girl going to
school in florida is listening to this
like
well listen i i i have like an image of
high school in the united states you
know because i used to watch movies and
stuff about what high school in the
united states is especially in the south
about it you go outside
you run
or you play football
you're gonna you're gonna have some type
of ball in your hand that's what you're
gonna do and if you're not in sports
then
i i don't know what to tell you did you
play football jordan yeah
we would do i would literally there's a
thing called power power pup powder puff
so like there's like a girl league like
in a different so was it was there a
film program did you do any of that like
in high school is there anything that
like
there was like
there was like an acting room and there
was like one acting class i did take one
kind of acting class i'm telling you the
curriculum is it's not good
like especially like just where i'm from
there's nothing good like i did do a
pageant one time
i was very involved i was involved in
this one thing called link leaders and
every single year in high school we
would get with the new freshmen
and just get them ready before school
started and we would stick with them
during their first couple weeks just
you know just getting them ready for
high school life and all that stuff so i
really enjoyed that and that
made me want to keep doing stuff in the
community like big brother big sister
program oh that was my school yeah
yeah we did i did that as soon as i
graduated high school went to college so
that type of stuff but oh it was just
sports sports sports so then here's the
loaded question it's like
you know it seems like our fates were
sealed how did i get myself like what
did you like
what was the genesis to this you know
what growing up i was obsessed with
watching
disney channel and i would always tell
my mom i said mom i'm gonna be on disney
channel i'm gonna and i also didn't
understand that it was fake what i was
watching so i thought i could go to
school with hannah montana and malibu it
was all this stuff
[Laughter]
hannah montana before she became miley
cyrus yeah yeah
and but then i don't know like my mom
and i come from a military family and
it's very just you know yeah
you get a job
so you can take care of the bills
there's no like dreams what are those
that doesn't pay the bills yeah and so
i got into college graduated with my
degree in advertising minor in marketing
and then
i obviously like i didn't know what to
do afterwards and like almost a year
went by and i just told my mom i was
like
you know remember the acting thing that
i kind of want to do that you wouldn't
let me do i'm just gonna go do it
and she was like you're stupid and i was
like all right
i'm going so now here i am
and it's working out you know and then
like it becomes like a snowball effect
when you want to do something and you
really have no idea and you're either
going to sink or swim so we have this
acting thing that's going and i got my
agents and went from doing background to
you know
did something with zach snyder the other
like oh yeah first night my buddy zack
but then along the way all these other
things start to happen and you
like
you learn production and there's other
aspects of the film industry not just
acting like when i was a little grown to
be like oh that's all there is to it no
when i met people like wes out here and
you see
that oh you can write you can direct you
can
just
hollywood a mic if that's all you want
to do there's so much that goes into it
and i love it i don't know so how did
you how did you go from how did you
improve your
acting over time and just your craft in
general because i think that's a
good question going into starting in a
school that didn't have
a v or any type of programs like that
where did you
because you're you know you can
you can be in kind of any scene we can
throw the camera on you and you can
you know and you can improvise and you
can be comedic or you can be serious
so where did you
where did you pick that up
i was the only child so i was very bored
and very like just dramatic and would
just dance and do all this stuff for my
family all the time
and i just i watch things and i feel
like i can mimic very well and that's
where i learned the idea of
acting like i understood like oh you can
just act this type of way you don't
actually have to be that type of way
person that's a legit skill though but
yeah everyone can do that right yeah and
then
i'm not going to say that acting is like
oh you have to be born with it but i do
think there is a level of just kind of
like what you're subconsciously capable
of doing you know and like where you can
allow your your emotions and body to go
can you let loose and like be
just completely kind of like see red you
know and just not care
because some people can't put those
blinders up or they they can't allow
themselves to become vulnerable was a
was to the death your first like big
acting thing with corridor specifically
yeah i guess so
i remember watching that and being like
dang jordan can act like yeah i mean and
when i came out here like i just found
myself around a bunch of creators and
whether it was short
instagram skits or whatever um
there's a lot of talented people out
here in los angeles and if you put
yourself around them and you start to
see the pool instead of looking at
people as competition
it's really really cool and then you
know i started taking acting classes as
well but
acting only helps you so much like it's
more of like the technical side and
understanding i like to break down the
script so you can make certain decisions
but they're still like
you know this like just doesn't lie
if you can't portray
that emotion i think that's a good
perspective too that what you
said there is just
looking at the pool instead of the
competition
looking at people as the people that you
know the people that you meet who are
you learn something from each of them
and instead of looking at that as a
negative and going oh it's so
competitive
you can look at it and go oh i now i
know this person who's really good at
this
i know this person is really good at
this and that and that and then all of a
sudden you build a stable of people that
you know
that you can
continue to make things with and that's
really that was always the trick for us
that's the thing that always worked for
us at corridor was just
you know we started off as just oh we
got
computers sam and nico no visual effects
i'll produce the videos
and then
people saw hey these guys are good at
that and through that we were able to
meet
you know
everyone we work with now
yeah keeping that open mind like
allowing that snowfall snowball effect
to take place is so important like to
not have such a strong hold on your
ideas and goals that you forget to allow
things to take its course because i
wouldn't be here at corridor if i just
didn't allow things to kind of take its
course yeah did you find like with punch
for punch specifically what like was
that like did you feel like you had like
a level up moment because i know you
were like pretty involved with that just
behind the scenes as well like
puncher punch was interesting because
i've never had to talk to
so many people who are also very
important
like pieces to the puzzle for something
you know so i'm like i'm talking to one
person and if their times don't match up
with this and then if they can't do this
or if they don't understand this and
what if they don't expect except this
budget like there's just so many things
you know behind the scenes that could
all come crumbling down and you just
hope that on the day of everyone is like
oh this is nice yeah you know everyone
shows up and plays the part that you
texted them last night at 12 a.m to do
or you know like just hope everything
goes great it was such a good
learning experience being able to just
logistically help
bring this together and man watching
this come to fruition is
absolutely wild yeah the uh the day
shift episode will be live
when this comes out i think yes same day
things yeah yeah so
monday the 15th uh
is which is this is live obviously
you're listening to it
dave the second the second episode of
punch for punch day shift is out and of
course the first episode we dropped uh
on the fifth
um so
you know if you like the first one
check out the second one it's it's fun
we put gui in a car and taught him how
to stunt drive for the first time in one
day yeah he's obsessed he wants to be on
the track all the time yeah i am like so
stoked to watch the second episode
because i like purposely haven't watched
that much of the day shift one because
i'm just like man i'm just stoked to
watch this and i loved the stranger
things one like it came i'm actually
excited to see what the cut down is on
that too because i mean yeah obviously i
was there every minute of just getting
it prepared but it's crazy to see
all of it just go down to 20 minutes
well and like the day shift set hours
only set that i wasn't on as a crew cuts
because uh team because uh daniel took
that whole thing so i've never seen the
movie i wasn't on set i haven't seen a
single cut i'm really excited because
i'm usually like so
just like a fly on the wall through the
whole thing that i'm like by the time it
comes out i feel like i've lived it like
a dozen times and it's not to say that
it's not good but it's like does it hit
you know you want that fresh
rush of like excitement i remember i
think day shift out of all of them was
one of the things like
being like an associate producer for it
you will put so much work into something
for it like that you don't know if it'll
pay off or if anyone will need it like
we had these cameras that i had i ended
up hand building spent hours
hours hours hours i don't know what time
i left the studio but then i also had to
be back and like up early the next day
because we're gonna be at the track
like we didn't even end up using the
cameras that i spent hours
and hours building i mean i went to so
many different stores like daniel's
helping me out because he's making a
whole video about it and then we get on
set and the wind is like
it was crazy like a 100 miles per hour
wind or something so was it that high
wasn't that high was it it was it's in
the crew
it was like 10 minutes it was like 200.
you have no idea i think it did get up
to 100. wow
wild because it got progressively worse
during the day
and that's what they told us yeah we got
there early and
all that to say yeah that's that's
production for you right and that was
also like the day after nico broke his
collarbone too oh yes and then that was
the day i had to go to nica's house and
drive his tesla for him because he
couldn't drive what a problem
yeah
i thought those things drove themselves
right i did i did try that feature out
i tried that feature i was it's really
cool i thought you could just tell them
where to go and then they show up no you
still have to like start it but then
like press a button and then you have to
touch the steering wheel every
yeah like 20 seconds or something
dude nico said something really cool
that reminds me of uh what you're
talking about with the
the spray paint the cameras and stuff
i've never heard this phrase before
correct me if i'm wrong if this makes no
sense maybe i'm remembering it
incorrectly but nico said planning
matters but plans don't matter which is
like the weirdest sentence but like
i think i've like it's been like ringing
in my ears i'm trying to decipher it but
i think what it's saying is like
it's important to plan like it's
important that you made the cameras but
like at the end of the day the plan
actually doesn't matter yeah it's the
act of planning yeah that is the
important part right it's like if you
don't use that it doesn't matter because
if that's not helping the story if
that's not just if it just didn't work
out that didn't work out it's like
training for it's like test it's like uh
studying for an exam
yeah yeah you know you study all this
material
you think hey this will help
but you don't get the questions to the
exam before
the exam and that's how real life is you
know you plan for things that's how real
productions are that's how any type of
work is you plan for it you do your best
to accommodate for the factors that you
know
might exist
but when you actually get there on the
day
you know something completely different
might happen it also hurts something
completely different it always happens
yeah you got to be flexible like that's
that is filmmaking
adapting to like and not freaking out
you know because there's people that'll
be like okay i guess like and then they
just have this horrible attitude it's
like you can't even care that it's
changing you just got to go with it and
have a good positive attitude or else
everything could go crumbling and the
people around you when you're working
with the crew oh my god yeah like uh
a bad sentiment is extremely contagious
like especially if it comes from the top
like the minute someone in charge seems
flustered on a on a film set
oh man like you just watch like it's
like it's a domino effect you're like oh
no and then suddenly it can change the
whole vibe of the shoe even if the shoes
went really well you know that was
something that i had to
pick up on as we started because when
when we first started filming videos it
was just me sam and nico
ren you know ren came along pretty early
as well and we we would be
just the four of us they're just just
three three four five of us filming
and
you know something would go wrong and
but it was it was so small and i didn't
think about
the
effect that
you know say oh
we can't film that right now because i
don't i didn't know about it you know
things like that as a producer
but when i started to see that
from if i had a negative attitude and i
saw how other people
would take that on
immediately i figured out oh no that's
that can't be the way that i do this
yeah because you're right it has an
immediate
yeah yeah it has an immediate
trickle-down effect um whether people
show it or not you'll feel it yeah yeah
fenrir i wanted to ask you i mean jonah
you were describing you know this moment
you're in
northern india you're on a nature
preserve you're taking pictures of god's
majestic creatures with a camera in your
hands for the first time you have an aha
moment where you realize that that's
what you want to do with your life
sounds like jordan and i are of the same
boat where we're kind of flexible and we
just like the act of doing fenner did
you have something like that in your own
life
uh
yeah i mean
i always
wanted to do
filmmaking whatever that meant um yeah
and i remember again a huge influence on
me was this other teacher we had in high
school her name was miss titus uh
georgina titus she was awesome
and she was actually i love how you
remember everyone's names yeah she was
she is a good one she was like her and
mitch talkers were two people that i'm
like okay you helped like mold the
person i am in a good way yeah
um and
she was my sister's teacher
and my sister was like in her she had a
graphic design class
and my sister was like super into that
class and she was a few years older than
me
um but basically we you know started to
learn photoshop through that and like uh
like adobe premiere
i think imovie at the time or whatever
it was as well
and
my sister was like oh you should you'd
probably like this and we'd just make
stupid little videos together like my
sister and i and then once i got to high
school i right away was like okay i
gotta be in this graphic design class
because i was like already learning
photoshop because it was just so much
fun i used to
my cousin i would like edit like pixel
art stuff in photoshop because we'd try
to make these little flash animations
and
basically like day one of the class i
was like oh i'm like sasha's little
brother i like i know how to use
photoshop already sasha taught me and
so basically just was doing photoshop
stuff and then kind of
like at some point i was kind of like
well this is kind of boring like
i'm just like doing still image stuff
and yeah i had a little like sony
handycam and loved filming stuff so i
was like okay how do i make photoshop up
for video and that's where yeah i
started learning after effects
and credit to miss titus as well she was
just like
yeah just like if you can do something
and show me like what you did and
explain how you did it i'll grade it
based on that like you don't have to do
the normal curriculum because she was
kind of like okay yeah you already know
how to do this stuff and then
i don't know why but for whatever reason
the school had the autodesk software
package like i guess they had some
promotion like schools could get it
somebody booted it someone someone free
booted it no i think they genuinely like
they were like oh we want to get
students learning this um and so
i didn't know anything about like 3dsm i
was using like google sketchups to be
like yeah i can do some cool
architecture stuff i don't know
and then
my teacher she was like okay well we
have these programs and she was
basically i don't know how to teach
these i've never opened them
can i assign you to open these and try
to figure out how to do something and
then if you show some other students
like i'll grade you based on that so
then i opened up i think it was like
yeah it was like 3ds max
and i remember doing like this super
simple walk animation of like the basic
rig they had in 3ds max
and i think uh softimage was the other
one
and i was like oh my god it's like
photoshop for video but in 3d space
yeah basically it was like
kind of told her after that i was like
yeah i want to just kind of keep doing
this so i'm just gonna
i kind of did the film class i kind of
turned it into that graphic design class
and this is all in high school yeah
that's dude
that is absolutely
similar to my experience because the
last year of school for me they came up
for the first time they had a
uh like a digital media class but i
signed up for it thinking oh i'm gonna
be able to make movies right yeah but
then they it's all like uh logo design
it's all like photoshop stuff but the
teacher tim precevich he
realized really quickly that like i only
was really there
because i want to make movies and so
he he literally i
i can't believe he did this but there
was like the little editing bay room in
the back and everyone else in the class
would do photoshop and he would just let
me go back there and i would i edited
for an entire semester i would go shoot
projects and
he was just like i guess made a deal
with me like i didn't even like
explicitly say like this he was just
like oh this kid like he wants to do
this so i would just make all these i
made every um we had like student uh
government so i made all the videos for
student government i made all there was
like people who were doing music videos
that they wanted all the music videos i
did um like we used to have these
assemblies where at some point wait wait
wait you tell them about you were
telling me about this the other day you
were slinging you were slinging uh
election videos for your high school
collection it was if you think i was so
dumb because i was the only one who was
doing it so you would have like you know
six people who are all over both sides
so you always end up yeah yeah dude
i made every single election video so
you would have these kids who were
directly
going against each other and all the
videos were made by the same guy you
know i was telling them what to say
basically
dude you're the like illuminati of this
school yeah guys we'll do free
concessions at the football games and uh
it's gonna be great yeah it was it's
thinking back on it made no sense at all
but um yeah that's what i did so it was
like a teacher who just like has
had the ability to see like oh like this
kid like has got like a thing that
they're really focused on like that's a
good teacher yeah because
it empowered me to feel like i i could
do those things yeah that's the
difference between like a good teacher
and a great teacher as a teacher that is
like
okay this kid is not
doing the curriculum but they're doing
something that is
you know valuable how can i encourage
and enable them to do that and that's
like
right i'm so thankful that i had those
mentors and teachers because i wouldn't
be where i am today without those people
so they don't exist in florida
they all escaped yeah maybe like a
couple in like my elementary yeah once
but like once you get into middle school
high school my community
it was just very like just
curriculum
this is for this exam test this even if
you pull out a granola bar detention
like they're just very to the books
and the books suck you know it's like
there is nothing special about it it's
it's the difference between the book
and the test
yeah yeah it's the same concept like you
you prepare
you you want to have a curriculum for
the kids you want to have a curriculum
for a class
but when you get the actual kids in
front of that curriculum
you might see
hey this one really is excelling in this
way this one's really excelling in this
way
and it doesn't quite fit the exact
curriculum but at the same time when you
have the goal established
what are you trying to teach with that
curriculum at the end of the day what's
the life skill
and you can still
go towards that thing that's that's kind
of the same concept yeah jake did you
have like a particular teacher or
teachers or people outside of that
without what kind of
molded you into this role
uh yeah i there was there was in the
school environment there was really two
i think there was uh
my coach scott christensen from track
and then um
this other man uh mr mr spreeman
um and
so
mr spreeman was a
history teacher but he also had taught
philosophy
um
and but they had axed the program
so he said oh well there's still
students i have that are interested in
this so we started a philosophy club i
know this is really nerdy but uh
yeah he basically taught me about the
fundamentals of like
you know western philosophy uh starting
with plato aristotle socrates you know
all the
the known greek greek greats and then
we had that's he he basically taught us
an improv course
on
the history of philosophy um and it was
really cool we would meet
at a
uh cafe uh like on thursday nights and
we would have reading every week that
we'd of course you didn't have to do it
there wasn't any requirement that you
had to do it but he saw hey all these
kids are interested in this
and then each one
you know was sort of establishing like
the pillars of thought and how
that progressed over time and who
challenged it and who thought
differently and
you know how that led up to today's and
the way that we think about
just you know everything today um
it was a really really good foundation
of that
and it kind of taught me for the first
time
how to teach myself things as well
because that's huge
yeah when you're you know younger you
you you get put in these okay this is an
educational environment right or your
parents might teach you something or vic
or whatever but when you figure out how
to teach yourself something that's
really when
education
pays its dues you know is is then you
can take the same approach to something
and go hey i might not know anything
about
13th century
english literature
but how do you start
well you you read a review on it you
read a view who is writing during that
period you pick up a book you you read
through it you figure out what separates
that from other parts of
you know the same
class i guess of
with this example being literature and
you bridge out from there
and i didn't know how to do that before
him
so that was really cool and that led me
into theology which i studied uh at in
college
um and then that led me into law
eventually because i liked philosophy
because it was really abstract and it
had this sort of a b logic to it yeah um
but i also
[Music]
it longed for something more for me
because
philosophy is great but if you can't
agree to like
you know some fundamental precepts about
the universe
you know which philosophy will do
there's philosophies who argue you know
we don't even exist man you know
it's like it's hard to it's hard to go
from any place when you start with such
a nihilistic yeah you know argument um
so that led me into theology and then i
started studying you know the religions
of the world and i noticed hey there's
actually
a lot of different themes that
connect across
different religions and and there's
actually
you know we often try to think of
different swaths of people and cultures
from the globe and these sort of cut and
dry boxes and you know you have hinduism
and you have
judaism and you have christianity and
buddhism but
there's there's themes that are central
to humanity
that run across those different
religions and they manifest themselves
in different ways and i didn't know that
until i started to study some of that
and and i liked that because it felt
connected to the actual human condition
and then of course
theology led me into
oh well wait there's more going on here
than just
the study of god there's there's
political
organizations that have been
created and built around this whole
thing that affect
the way we are today or the way that our
societies are today and then that led me
to think oh well
how what is the glue
that holds
society and culture together well it's
it's law
it's these concepts of law it's not like
oh we wrote this down in a book so you
need to follow it i'm talking about the
the concept of
like the legal contract that we have
with one another or the social contract
that we have with one another and that
led me down that path
so that was my sort of
way that i came to be in law school and
then of course while i was in law school
we started filming videos and i thought
hey
i can
apply
my passion to learn something new
to this now and that's what i did
i didn't know anything about filmmaking
before i started working with sam and
nico i did i mean i shot a couple films
i had opened movie maker you know i had
messed around with video cameras and
still photography and things like that
but
everything i learned i i learned
from just
being here and doing it yeah jake have
you watched uh better call
saul i've never seen it dude
have you seen breaking bad yeah i've
seen it i've seen a few episodes but it
was honestly it was really hard for me
to watch because it's so intense dude oh
it's so good better call saul the final
episode is coming out on monday and
might be better than breaking bad wow
it's because i think it'd be right up
your alley man it's such like incredible
filmmaking but then it has this whole
like
lost like it's very much what you were
talking about just like the social
contracts like how do we
you know yeah
like bend the law how do we take
advantage of this how do we you know
like what is morally the correct thing
to do if you know you're representing
someone that's like
you know a criminal like there's right
without spoiling like there's scenes
where it's like oh i'm needing to defend
someone that i know
is like
heavily involved in this cartel because
they threatened me
representing this person because they're
threatening to kill me like how does
this like
and it's dude it's such a good show i
think i think if you could watch through
breaking bad and then do better call
saul it's it's so incredible it's a good
double feature of like what that's like
two weeks of your life dude that's like
that's like a month
when i started law school i did it
because i wanted to protect
uh well i did i wanted to be a music a
musician's agent or
i wanted to work in music because that's
that's the artistic format that i was
familiar with yeah but when i started
doing video i realized oh that same
principles apply and so my whole idea
behind it was
i want to
become a lawyer so i can not get screwed
by a lawyer yeah and that was that was
my whole idea yeah um
so far it's worked out but uh
wait wait jake how's it going with the
warner brothers
dude
i i have no updates on it at this time i
but it's the podcast that you guys share
it's coming it's coming we still have
another 45 days of the copyright strike
so i got some time still those wb
lawyers dude maybe uh maybe we can stick
it to them again and maybe uh yeah
that little uh
you know yeah that's really poking the
bear yeah so uh warner brothers you may
have heard
speaking of speaking up yeah they
canceled this movie
called batgirl
and
you know
we were just thinking playing around
with the idea of
oh it's canceled what if we make it so
i don't know what if we just what if we
just leak it you know what if we just
dude it's worse than canceling it
because from what i understand they shot
most of it it's not like they like
canceled the movie from being produced
like they produced it yeah it was like
in post like they were editing there's
the effects being done
was showing me my soon-to-be costume
yeah oh yeah
i have to buy my own costume because
it's my department as well yeah
you have to talk to the producer you're
having a conversation with yourself
i don't know maybe there's a cheaper
option i don't know i don't know if it's
in the budget please
but i just there's so much there with
like warner brothers and the whole all
the controversy with like
ezra miller and
that like how is that movie still being
released and
that's there's a lot going on there so i
feel like it's
some very uh interesting opinions on
this so i think uh once we get into the
production of this it'd be great to get
him back on the cast and have him go
into some of those because
yeah i don't know what's going on over
there i don't know if they're going to
be
around for
new things
dude like well i mean i don't
yeah so okay so
this is they they were recently acquired
by discovery right yeah which is like so
bizarre yeah and we
i don't want to
hot take discovery has had also had its
own
issues right because they tried to make
the streaming service right because
discovery bought it wasn't like cnn plus
or something where they tried to have a
streaming service and it lasted like i
think two weeks
yeah and then they're like oh this was
horrible and then they like kind of
restructured they laid everyone off and
now they're buying warner brothers and
i'm like well your track record
very bad
right and then the other thing about so
you're talking about
hbo max
and discovery plus yeah
so basically let let's just set that on
a table for a second
and and for you know we don't know the
in and outs of this right now i don't
know
some people do obviously but we don't
but let's just set those two concepts on
a table you have hbo max you have
discovery plus
they're basically
not even the same
product yeah at all you know yeah
they're video audio visual product that
you consume by watching in four frames
or in four corners of a frame
but beyond that
hbo max
is this entirely different
you know has this entirely different
legacy and heritage versus discovery
plus
which is
reality tv
yeah and and you know cheap like
reality tv documentary style you know
you got what do you got deadliest catch
and ice cream
truckers
is on history oh really but yeah like i
think discovery i think mythbusters i
think hbo i think like i don't know like
game of thrones or something yeah you
think you think cinematic narrative yes
versus reality tv and the market for
those is is there's two totally separate
markets for that so
i don't know how they're gonna reconcile
that and make them feel like one
cohesive platform
um
you know uh
and
it's almost as if you know the
i don't know is
is there any art left in like discovery
channel content or is it just is it just
content
the the marketing for shark week is
perhaps the most artistic thing that
they've ever done
yeah
um and you know disney and netflix and
amazon and hbo there's still
there's there's there's this concept
that is inherent still to those
platforms which is this is still an art
form
we might not get it right all the time
you know we've got shareholders we've
got stocks we've got all that crap
but
we still do things that are cool and
cutting edge and isn't that fun and
don't you want to see it
versus
hey how about that next season of ice
road truckers guys i don't know if i
show truckers is on discovery plus and
i'm sure if you told that to an
eight-year-old if i told my son that i
showed truckers had a new season he'd
probably be all about it yeah but
yeah
something by by
widening the viewership ever is that
that's kind of what you're saying it's
like because it does it degrade game of
thrones for it to be sitting next to ice
road truckers right because you could
assume they have to do a tie-in episode
[Laughter]
but you can't like stray away from the
idea of just like human nature in our
minds and
saying they say don't judge a book by
its cover well like that's all we do
like in this industry who's directing
this movie oh is it on netflix it is is
it on here if it's not on a certain
platform or streaming service or in
movies we aren't going to take it yeah
seriously and there's a future there's
an audience
there's a few that break out by word of
mouth but they're few and far between
have you guys seen have you guys seen
prey yes i have i still haven't seen it
how is that not in theaters i know it is
incredible it's one of the best like
it's weird other than the original it's
like the best predator movie i've seen
in a long time and it's just genuinely
one of the best action
movies i've seen it's so well shot what
did i watch it what's it yeah what's
this on hulu
and i'm like
but you know what like the rooms that
we're not in like these executives and
the money and the hollywood and the
corporate first it's some sketchy stuff
happening up there and who has their m
their pockets and what in their hands
and what we don't know i just listened
to
um last night uh on the ringer podcast
the big picture um they were
interviewing dan trachtenberg the
director
and they asked them they're like what do
you think about your movie only coming
out on hulu and he you could tell he was
like
yeah you know
we shot it on location it's beautiful
he's like i really think it should be in
theaters like and you could tell he was
like oh man how is this only now being
released to like
view on home video like we watched it on
an ipad and i'm like
yeah yeah i was like i would pay so much
money to go see a double feature of the
original predator and pray back to back
like and i'm just saying the fact i
watched licorice pizza
in theaters but i can't go watch prey i
know theaters is absolutely wild it's so
good it's like
incredible the effects incredible
cinematography amazing sound design like
and i was just like this is such a shame
like yeah yeah it's seriously like if
you guys haven't seen it go check out
prey because it is it's interesting do
you think that maybe like
the idea of going to the movies versus
just what platform it's on like that's
just going to start kind of bleeding
into each other like the idea of a
blockbuster film because it's in a movie
theater is no longer going to be really
just
yeah well it already i mean it already
does that a little bit it's already yeah
that's already happening a bit yeah and
kova didn't help
yeah i mean it pushed that it pushed
that further yeah um but i i don't think
that necessarily
matters
as long as you can
absorb it
in that same type of environment where
you can sit and it's
big screen there's good sound it's
isolated you're meant to sit down and
absorb it and watch every shot
and not get up
yeah and and move on so i
that medium obviously is
i think going to be preserved however
because people enjoy consuming
videos like that um but yeah i think
there'll always be a place for theaters
i just don't know how
you know i i don't i don't know we've
had this conversation a lot to do this
with movies just because they're in
theaters or not anymore i think that's
where streaming is getting us yeah isn't
um i could be totally wrong on this but
aren't some of the streaming services
purchasing their own theaters yeah i was
about to say like if you this is so full
circle because like if you look at the
history of like cinema and like the
golden era of like
when the star system was like kind of
invented in the like the reason like
paramount theater is named the paramount
theaters because it was like it was a
studio lot it was production it was
distribution and that
is illegal
that's called
monopoly
and yeah you used to be able to sign
talent to uh a contract with just a
specific studio so we're running into
this weird place where it's like yeah it
would be cool if there was a hulu
theater right i would go to the hula
theater and watch prey that's great but
there's a reason we dismantle that
system right the vertical integration
system because it makes it even harder
for
like any form of competition to exist
right yeah and
the the space is a little different now
because like yeah a director can like
get their projects put on hulu right
like a guy like who makes prey can like
get you know it's it is different but
as fun as it would be for
us to be able to go to the the hula
theater and watch it i actually think in
the long term it would it would be worse
um just from like a like a business
standpoint
it's just dangerous i'm so curious to
see what happens with prey because it's
already become hulu's biggest thing
they've ever had really yeah like and it
just came out watch this movie well i
mean it doesn't stop it from getting its
awards and recognition exactly but i'm
i'm so curious if they're gonna do a
theater launch of it
because i would go
i mean if they can make money off of it
they will that like that's basic
distribution right there you just hook
up with a distribution partner
you know whoever it is there's a bunch
of them out there
and you sling it out to theaters i mean
that's
if they think that it'll do well they'll
do it there's people who are hungry for
that because of how
dry
the theater market is now
um so they'd be looking for that i'm
sure they're already talking about it
yeah we were saying after we watched it
it was like man we like we looked at
what was playing in the theaters and it
was like
everything was a superhero movie or
there was also nope but that was the
only other like non-superhero movie and
it's just because it's like
you know if you slap marvel on it it's
probably gonna do decent numbers so
those will
be shown in theaters but it's
it's a it's kind of a shame that you
don't get movies like prey
like i'm wondering if they thought it
wouldn't do well
you know yeah i guess it's just they
also pro the way that those contracts
work now too is it's just
uh it's very simple it just says hey
this is your budget we want you to make
it this is your distribution platform
yeah and they don't really consider
that you know that's a whole new i don't
know what the budget is on it budget was
on it we can look that up real quick
yeah i mean whatever it looked
phenomenal like the way it shot the vfx
like i was like the budget will give you
a lot of indication in terms of what the
initial contract probably was about yeah
it just goes to show like yeah i feel
like it's probably pretty low budget and
like a director if you could knock it
out of the park that hard you become
undeniable and that's the whole thing is
like to to
re like these days it has to be
undeniable yeah well after listening an
interview he talked about some of his
past projects and i was like oh man i
didn't realize this guy was one of my
favorite directors i didn't even know
like he did 10 cloverfield lane uh he
did the episode playtest of black mirror
oh okay like he's only done
banger stuff but it's all been streaming
service kind of stuff because wasn't the
only thing that drives me nuts on the
street 10 cloverfield lane is it has no
ending yeah i know it's just like
it's a thriller without an ending yeah
why yeah i think streaming's taking over
i don't know you don't say
yeah
speaking of questions
the system and yeah like you're watching
this paying 3.99 um well like something
like rebel moon like i would go to
theaters to watch that right when it
drops
strictly on netflix yeah netflix
streamer only okay but on but let's go
back a quick let's let's just wrap this
up with going back to that
monopoly thing yeah yeah yeah i love
that game what are we talking about
you're talking about vertical breaking
up vertical integrations in different
industries guys when's the last time
there was a good
breakup
of a monopolized industry
yeah we haven't done it in a while well
no we're we've flirted with it a lot and
like outside of film i don't know
there's a lot of virtue signaling about
it but when's the last time
there was actually a good breakup of a
like is amazon too big you know it's
that kind of question yeah it's it they
like
this was all started because of standard
oil and
and they broke that up into a billion
different companies but
we could use a little bit of that you
know not just in entertainment but
kind of a crosstalk you know he's using
things up a little bit yeah it's easier
to do an entertainment because
everyone's looking you know yeah right
like entertainment because it's like
it's like a mirror right because
entertainment is talking about
entertainment so they're right we're so
bad
right
and so it's like it's a fun little
playground to talk about these things in
but yeah when it comes to like the
greater you know you know actual like
business interests of this
country and countries around the world i
think that
we're we're far past due for a lot of
these
these things so let's let's get into
that on the next podcast
okay i make movies on the next corridor
cast we're going to talk about
big corp breakups and what they mean
with all of our
extensive experience
the families like the rockefellers and
the rocks
did we forget about it i just you know
what i forgot about that amazon also a
streaming service apple also yeah
they're just oh yeah see what i mean see
what i mean yeah yeah
someone say whatever
oh god no that's all the conspiracy
theorists own these corporations okay i
just want you all to remember
jordan's going way down on it dude they
we don't even know what they look like i
don't want to i gotta go up to the uh
i gotta go to the kitchen and get you a
tinfoil hat because you're getting
you're moving a lot
he's going she's going reptilians that's
next dude if i don't come to to work
tomorrow
it's because they found me yeah
jordan you're being back girl
you want to uh
i'm so excited to be back girl i really
hope that i actually have like just a
range yeah that i can showcase oh i
don't want to just do a bunch of dumb
[ __ ] the whole time okay do you want to
we maybe have another role that might
have some range oh yeah jonah was
writing something halo yeah yeah we did
that i was gonna let you say it but i
was so excited yeah we and that one's
like no like
no pressure yeah jacob have you heard
about this you like the whole thing
yes so this is this is also uh
something that fenner and jonah are in
the works on now that you guys are
roomies
yeah i mean look at these bearded
uh profoundly intellectual high schools
didn't you guys do between the ages of
like eight and fifteen
figure beards jordan they grew beers
but yeah man halo is something that i
think is a really interesting
opportunity um and it it's kind of in
line with uh you know something we've
all been talking about here which is
like you know we just wrapped up two
really big
um
long-form projects right which is like
punch for punch and son of a dungeon
which is like oh son of a lot is not
wrapped yeah we're not wrapped up sorry
i just that was a huge faux pas i'm
gonna hear about that later at home
but uh you know we're in a we're in a
place where
you know we have the opportunity to do
some smaller and not smaller in the
sense of like less important but like
you know
quicker turnaround kind of short stories
and yeah as like a guy who's like a fan
of quarter like that's what i loved like
i've watched every single one of those
and and i think having a balance is
really great and fenner came to me with
this idea
you know mad scrawlings and and uh you
know random ideas of of halo what this
halo short could be and we've been
working on it for a couple months and i
think it only makes sense that you're
the lead it's like a really dope
character um you know it's uh we i don't
want to say too much about it but um
it's gonna be
a really awesome opportunity for you to
be like
yeah like
a badass a badass and like can't wait
man dope little story can't wait to read
the script
yeah you'll get it on your desk very
soon i'm sure uh okay
and uh yeah is there anything else like
what do you want to say uh
i'm like scared right now
it looks cool center's in charge i've
started working on some of the vfx for
it oh like and it's
i
when we were talking with sam and nico
about it we said we're like we want this
to be
this is gonna put so much pressure on
ourselves we want this to be the best
looking thing corridor has done
which is so much pressure
but you're right here
i feel like the best looking thing we've
done in the halo universe
yeah
yeah
but yeah how does that make you feel as
the as master chief are you offended
that he wants something is there a way
to be better than listen
we didn't we didn't set the bar that
high let's be honest
but yeah we were going more for the
comedy of it
yeah we're gonna i don't know try our
best on this thing and i think it could
be something really cool so i'm
like
really stoked about it so yeah this is
the short is not funny it's like a dope
like yeah actually like it's very much
like a slice of like
what
i and fenner both think like halo could
be as
like a film property or like a you know
at least a streaming property like yeah
it's very much
you know fender's coming at it as like a
fan of the property i'm coming i'm not
like
a huge fan of halo in the sense that i
just don't know much about it but like
i'm coming at it saying like how do we
make a story in this world like
compelling and important and also pay
homage but not over indulge it has to
work for people that no no i don't know
anything like and i you know i've never
played i wear the sweatshirt that we
have a corridor it's a halo gun that's
not all i know but i'm very i'm really
excited i'm gonna act my ass off for you
guys
yeah i'm super excited because that's
awesome
dungeon we have like so much
technological uh
advancements that we're gonna definitely
incorporate that's all i have to say on
it yeah i'm very excited for that part
too for sure
so we have that in the in development
and then we just pulled dubstep guns to
past development it's now officially in
pre-production
um so we have ideal shoot dates we're
getting into the nitty-gritty about you
know the designs of the props and the
script is done so now that's in full
pre-production which is awesome it's
been a long time coming thank you for
everyone's patience while we did
son of a dungeon season two um and now
we get to spend some time on that uh
nico's got another iteration of the to
the death universe that he's writing
i don't even know that yeah yeah i just
found out
you told me um during korean barbecue on
friday i almost pooped my pants
yeah
yeah so that's related it was just
korean barbecue
it was just the korean barbecue yeah
and then uh we also have uh the
first i guess this would technically be
the second episode of wizard cops
because the first one we did years ago
this would be since it got greenlit we
have the first draft of the script for
that
um so yeah that's all i can't wait for
that is that
you're writing
yeah i've written the first um nico did
a pass on uh like some scenes and
situations that he thought would be
funny then i took that and i have my own
scenes and things and like that in there
it's about 10 pages right now um
the big question that we were facing was
whether to make it more narrative or
make it really no it's just cops with
wizards which i think we're leaning more
towards no really no it's just cops with
wizards because it's just so funny
yeah
um so we're gonna lean more into that
and then finish up the first script for
episode one and then i think we're just
gonna shoot it and we're not because you
know when we and originally
conceptualized that the idea was oh well
maybe let's
you know do five episodes at once
let's just do one
and then put it out and then do another
one and put it out and and just do it
that way and then it doesn't have to be
this big thing that like creates this
space-time continuum void in the rest of
everything else we're doing
um so
yeah i'm really excited for this fall
because we're gonna get into more of
this type of work and it's just gonna
sharpen everyone's skills and
come up with you know new energy and new
ideas for stuff so yeah oh wait speaking
of sharpening skills yes and here we
have a an improv class
maybe yes yeah yeah is that actually i'm
very excited for because i believe it is
happening i don't
yeah
i don't know anything about it beyond
that i've been taking a break from my
acting classes because they're so
expensive because i'm moving into my new
apartment yeah and when i was told that
we have basically an acting class coming
here that i can take first so if you
think markiplier is good at improv
just know this is the woman who
[Music]
taught him how to improv wow yeah so
that we can all sharpen our skills here
yeah our intern mike are we is it like a
one day event or are we like is his name
mike
mark i don't know he does the dishes
he makes he makes new rooms i don't know
nico described him as a benevolent
youtube god the other day
yeah and that's when youtube god is
correct
mark is awesome so yeah yeah
he's awesome
so that's that's what's on the docket
people um i think that's it for for this
episode of the quarter cast thank you
for joining
um
and uh
listening and uh we hope you're having a
great day um i guess i'll i guess i'll
play us out what do you guys think yeah
that was a fun podcast that was really
fun i learned a lot
your speech on your like process of
going from philosophy to theology it
made me have a great deal of respect for
you i had never heard any of that it was
really cool i want to hear more about
that that was like because i i did i did
a bit of that in college i took like
three or four different that's when i
was able to do philosophy too we can
talk about that actually because my
florida just keep talking keep talking
i'm gonna start playing just quietly
yeah oh yeah this is like interesting
ensure
[Music]
my ex-husband i love all you guys
this is falling apart
that's what happens when they play the
music you start crumbling no but you
know i think what i learned today
this is my crew cut speaking we gotta
always have a good moment at the end to
wrap it up what i learned today is that
you know we got to embrace
what we learned with being young and
just having the ability to
the fervor for excitement um
and to learn everything and to not get
to in your head about like
making everything perfect yes you know
just about like who you should be yeah
just explore learn as much as you can
don't put too much pressure on yourself
you know she
she pressure
but she humbles you humble
and that's what's important to remember
um
[Music]
that's all i got
just go out there and have fun thanks
for watching everybody